[Musique]
il était une fois cinq vieux amis ils se
connaissaient depuis très longtemps très
très longtemps
il vivait dans la baie des chaleurs en
gaspésie dans le charmant petit village
de saint alphonse de caplan les
montagnes de bois en poudre marqué le
paysage tout comme les mollets avant et
des créatures sauvages
un camion de pompier tout neuf faisait
la fierté de la place les copains sylvie
responsable du sentier écologique des
chutes du ruisseau creux
christian producteurs de tomates
biologiques en serre d'éthane
propriétaire du dépanneur et du poste
d'essence bertin l'ancien maire du
village et homme d'entretien et sa
conjointe chantal directrice du centre
culturel souvent en groupe ils rêvaient
à leur avenir
lors des soupers de gangs mais ça me
souvent ça se voit sur le sujet le
canton va être view serait le fun qu'on
vive ensemble talons hauts les chansons
choisies avec robin c'est déjà un gros
point la retraite ça dure longtemps
féculent fans de faire ça ensemble puis
koné sera moi aussi dans une cabane tout
ce que tout le monde ne m'a jamais meurt
puis il me l'a même affaire quand on
veut pendant trente ans attendre virer
fou
[Musique]
la maison de dieu demeure à mains nues
dans les années 50 les religions étaient
au centre de la vie de saint-alphonse
depuis partout au québec
les églises ont été désertés ici le
presbytère était vide depuis 25 ans dans
un avenir proche pour viol a dû passer à
une démolition ya sept ans la fabrique
décide pour sauver l'église et refaire
le toit de vendre le presbytère nos cinq
camarades saute sur l'occasion
trois mille 800 pieds carrés sur deux
étages
six chambres à coucher trois salles de
bains une immense cuisine pour 40000
dollars
ils deviennent propriétaires phase de
chantier au fur et à mesure qu'on rénove
comme dans la salle de bain ou la douche
est fait pour qu'on puisse rentrer
facilement même chose voulant un des
grands défis du projet sera de vivre
ensemble dans ces communes nouveau genre
et si c'était un grand salon des
partenaires extérieurs jusqu'à l'eau
pure extérieur
pour l'instant seuls sylvie et christian
myon emménagent il fait la chasse aux 2
d'une dame à paspébiac qu'elle soit dans
une grange on avait deux trois jeux fait
restaurer
j'ai commencé ma vie de jeune adulte
normal en commune ça a été des
expériences extraordinaires puis j'ai
perdu ma première entreprise en gagne
pas lors de gros pour moi c'est aussi de
ma vie
une fin de semaine par mois c'est la
corvée l'extérieur a été repeint au
grand plaisir des villageois cette fois
ci on retape le salon d'accueil petit
bonhomme là
[Musique]
ce désir de plus en main se manifeste
partout dans la province
comme dans les cantons de l'est ou à
tous les mois au moins deux groupes
d'aînés approche guillon drian baby
boomers dalphond arrive à un âge où ils
disent comment on va organiser notre
retraite
les prochaines années de quoi rotella
1,5 a mis le vieux presbytère est devenu
en l'an 2000 une coopérative
d'habitation pour aînés ce qui lui a
donné accès à du financement et à de
l'encadrement technique
c'est si la belle grande charme cette
époque pour être un loyer c'est un peu
plus tard il y a neuf appartements 4
dans le presbytère et 5 construit à
l'arrière
je t'en veux que la couturière de la
place c'est d'être ensemble c'est comme
une famille face y'a pas un de mes
enfants qui est proche j'apprécie
beaucoup et se disent on est peut-être
rendus à la veillée notre vie à la
soirée mais la soirée va être longue et
on va avoir beaucoup de plaisir avec
soin comme philosophie et comme manière
d'organiser toute l'habitation et le
milieu ça on change le monde nous unit
gaspésia ne savent pas encore s'ils vont
choisir la formule coopérative ils n'ont
pas eu à demander ni en preuve ni
subvention en attendant ils ont signé
une convention traitant des aspects
monétaires et du code de vie on s'est
fait des règlements généraux
on a les départs et les exclusions parce
que c'est bien de prévoir quand on est
toutes de bonnes vagues qu'on est tout à
sylvain de bonnes bouteilles de vin
qu'on est tous d'accord
en près de 50 ans de pratique m cormier
a vu bien des expériences de
cohabitation mal tourné vous allez vous
avoir des dames à rouler ou avoir la
possibilité d' expulsion on peut passage
chez soi mais une fois les 28 ans amène
des progrès de santé amène des problèmes
ce ferry les ai dit que moi quand je
années qu'on fait beaucoup de corvée
ensemble qu'on se bouge choses ensemble
que on s'est mis à l'épreuve où son
épaule n'est face à ces questions et
lecture elle président de l'upe et à
l'union des producteurs agricoles de la
gaspésie les îles un leader dans la
communauté
le sera-t-il ici je demande saut dans le
vide que je leur prouve aussi quand on
parle de travaux comme tel ce verdict le
plus d'expérience
fortement des hallyday on a tous des
qualités puis tout le monde peut les
exprimer ici de c'est ma classe de repos
ce ma place de relaxation c'est
aujourd'hui dissous le monde le garçon
un peu curieuse main puis dans le fond
j'espère que ça va bien fonctionner moi
personnellement je suis plutôt du genre
solitaire je pense pas que je pourrai il
va vous la journée où on dit cink on
veut quelqu'un pour faire l'entretien ou
faire les rappeurs afin qu'on peut se
payer une personne à temps plein on peut
créer un emploi pour quelqu'un puis ça
permet aussi à ceux qui veulent voyager
aussi de partir sans inquiétude
deux jours ces opportunités de promotion
était une solution qui en même temps un
beau défi et on aura deux maisons à
faire virer à gagne avec mon petit
économique peut-être en notre nom petit
pauvreté front à grande échelle cinéma
c'est ainsi que cent vingt ans après sa
construction
ce un colloque se sont réapproprié le
presbytère qu'ils ont baptisé la part
des anges
[Musique]